how old are you i'm 20. you're 20. when
you think about you and your friends
explain my brother here is 24. uh 25 now
25 25 25. uh and we talk a lot about the
psychological difference of how
20 24 25 year olds think about financial
markets than uh the older generation
even me at 33 i'm kind of in the middle
of some of those folks
how do you think about
equities bonds crypto bitcoin versus
anything else like are you and all of
your friends all in on bitcoin or do
they have diversified portfolios like
how do you guys think through uh
investing
yeah so um i mean i had kind of quite
the the orange pill moment i would say
over the last couple years um and i've i
think i've gotten most of my friends
there as well but um i kind of think of
it like you know going back to the
manipulated cost of capital and legacy
finance um
there's just no way that i'm ever going
to buy a bond at least at least in
today's environment it's just you know
there's there's just no way in hell i'm
never going to fund the us government
for one percent a year in nominal terms
um when you're thinking about equities
there's also because of this broken
manipulated cost of capital
you're looking at sky-high p e ratios
all-time high corporate debt to gdp i
just think um from a risk reward
standpoint it's not too attractive and
honestly i i think i firmly believe that
over the next 10 years equities will
will rip in nominal terms i think um
they'll do very well but when you're
when you're looking at this on a on a
real basis i think they they might they
might not do too great especially when
you're when you're calculating the
opportunity cost uh in bitcoin terms
because um i mean if you if you couldn't
tell i have kind of i've come to this uh
conclusion or i have this thesis that
that the risk-free rate of everything
the opportunity cost of everything is
bitcoin um and you know people will say
like are you kidding me it drew down 50
in a couple months um but i'm not
thinking on that time frame i'm thinking
um you know years decades and so i know
i know one thing for sure is that um the
cost of producing bitcoin will continue
to go up forever essentially um because
of the economic incentives and because
of basically how this protocol works um
the havings the difficulty adjustment
you know everything we've covered and so
when i think about how do i want to
allocate my my wealth how do i want to
save my time and energy into the future
with bitcoin priced under a trillion
dollars
there's basically no other place that i
would think about allocating capital at
the moment um and i think
diversification um in in this sense is
not something that that i'm uh really
too too interested in um i mean i do own
some bitcoin related equities with it
you know a few basis points in my
portfolio but for the most part stacking
straight to cold storage and and you
know that's it because you know i can
handle a 50 drawdown my volatility at 20
years old is not something i'm too
concerned with um you know it's a
different story for someone that's 65
and and you know needs to needs to you
know draw from that capital every day
but um that's just not the case for me
so you know stacking stats and and just
chilling
what's up guys bang bang thanks so much
for watching the best business show
today if we're gonna be the best
business show we obviously need the best
partner that's why the exclusive sponsor
the best business show is sofi they're
an all-in-one platform that allows you
to invest in all kinds of different
assets including stocks etfs crypto ipos
and they even have an automated
investing function if that's your thing
so before we start getting after it
again make sure that you go download
sofi you get an invest account and when
you make your first crypto trade
regardless of what you buy they'll give
you 10 in bitcoin for free it's that
simple head on over to sofi.com to get
started today thanks so much for
watching and i hope you come back and
watch more the best business show
tomorrow
[Music]